human beatbox
questa era una classica routine di uno
human beatbox la musica e l'arte dei
suoni la human beatbox è la stessa
identica arte soltanto che i suoni hanno
un'origine diversa ovvero umana che può
essere di bocca o via vocale il mio
primissimo approccio con la human
beatbox attraverso la piattaforma
globale di youtube
all'interno di questa piattaforma trovai
beatboxer di nome rise and rise el era
un beatboxer americano human beatbox
americano dal quale deriva il mio nome
ansell ma di lui parleremo dopo i suoni
fondamentali dello human beatbox sono
tre abbiamo il kit ovvero la cassa
abbiamo il piatto abbiamo il gretto
ovvero in gergo ai ed infine abbiamo il
rullante ovvero lo snake su questi tre
suoni 6 conglomerati riescono a generare
una vera e propria sequenza ritmica come
ad esempio la cosa più divertente di
questa sequenza ritmica fin da quando
ero piccolo e che ne esiste una versione
al contrario ovvero la versione in
reverse che fa così
ok tutto è bello fighissimo gay però vi
starete chiedendo giustamente come fa
uno human beatbox air a prendere fiato
nel mentre che fa beatbox beh il
concetto di respirazione in sessi si
divide in due modi perché i ogni singolo
suono
io mi seguono non esistono due versioni
la versione outward è la versione in
word la versione outward di un suono è
la versione ispirata come ad esempio uno
snack qualunque il ring sotto vedete
butto giù l'aria e dello stesso suono ne
esiste la versione in word ovvero li
nord che isner
facciamo così che messi insieme generano
questo sì potrei andare avanti ore ed
ore ma è meglio di noi
la prima persona ad aver inizializzato
il tutto fu doggy fresh dog i flash
negli anni 80 ebbe la necessità di
sostituire la figura del dj ovvero di
quella persona che comunque fa la musica
all'interno della scena dell'hip hop
anche modo sfruttando i tre suoni
fondamentali in maniera molto semplice
perché all'epoca non si era così
articolati esempio
successivamente a giochi flash ci fu
russell raz el ebbe la brillante idea
negli anni 90 di aggiungere la melodia
all'interno di questa struttura ma in
che modo attraverso il naso
in questo modo infine ci fu y y cambiò
totalmente le regole del gioco perché
aggiunse tre caratteristiche all'interno
di una struttura di un beatboxer che
erano un nuovo slayer completamente
nuovo chiamato il ring sotto non c'è
precedentemente nominato che suonava
così sono un vero e proprio basso vocale
e degli effetti sonori vari come ad
esempio un ball e insieme
immaginate faceva questo modo
y è fondamentale all'interno del
movimento dello human beatbox perché
perché fu quello che realizzò una scuola
di pensiero nominata nuova scuola
la nuova scuola in gergo new school
nasce negli anni 2000 a punto e si basa
sui tecnicismi sul lato più tecnico
della struttura di uno human beatbox air
e oltre a questo si basa anche sulla
strati smo del suono come ad esempio un
suono qualunque chiamato liquid bass o
come ad esempio il vortex o come ad
esempio uno zip
essendo che io sono nato nella nuova
scuola come potete ben vedere spesso
andata una nuova scuola e diciamo che ho
avuto un problema abbastanza grosso ok
nell'interfaccia armi con le persone
nell avere un approccio col mio beatbox
professore persona perché le persone
avevano reazione ha pressoché negative
giustamente magari mettiamo un esempio
una signora anziana che cammina riva al
mare alle 6 del mattino arrivo io cioè
nel senso la sua reazione non sarà o ma
che bravo sarà uno scappellotto
ok e di conseguenza io ho dovuto
rimediare ma in che modo ponendomi delle
domande ponendo delle domande però prima
a me stesso e successivamente a delle
persone con molta più competenza di bit
boxers con più esperienza di me
diciamo che tutti mi hanno risposto allo
stesso modo si più musicale è infatti
qui subentra la vecchia scuola in gergo
old school nata negli anni 90 che è come
struttura che altro un concetto più
melodico una struttura più musicale di
uno human beatbox air e diciamo che oggi
cerco di stare in equilibrio tra la
nuova e la vecchia scuola ma la vecchia
scuola cosa ci insegna ci insegna che
bisogna apprezzare la concretezza del
suono come ad esempio quello di uno
strumento tradizionale ad esempio il
violino adesso vi starete chiedendo come
fa uno human beatbox era riprodurre la
frequenza di un violino in perle logica
come non è impossibile siete d'accordo
come è vero è impossibile
e qui subentra la tecnologia ma in che
modo con l'ausilio di una loop station
la loop station oltre che garantirmi il
fatto di poter generare la stessa
frequenza di un violino
in questo modo
mi permette di realizzare dei veri e
propri brani
punto
vecchia scuola nuovo a scuola
tutti